Tom, have you ever fallen asleep during a
movie in theaters?
At the movies.
At the movies?
Yeah.
Almost definitely, yeah.
You know what?
The second Alice In Wonderland movie with
Johnny Depp.
Yeah.
I fell asleep during the first act and I woke
up and Wonderland had turned into a scab.
Nina, what are the worst films that Hollywood's
best actors have been in?
I think you...
I feel you have an answer to this question.
I do.
So please tell me what it is.
It's locked and loaded.
So imagine that it is late 2019, and you're
going to the movies and you're seeing a movie
that stars Tony Award winner Ian McKellen,
Tony Award winner James Gordon, Academy Award
winner Judy Dench, Academy Award winner Jennifer
Hudson, Emmy nominee Idris Elba, and Rebel
Wilson is also in this film.
Imagine all of that and more.
Jason Derulo's there for some reason.
I can't picture a movie like this.
Well.
What movie could you possibly talk...
A movie like this must be amazing, that wouldn't...
Right?
This cast has got legs and it sounds like
it always lands on them.
This sounds so good.
Yeah.
This cast has-
What's this movie?
Nine lives because it's Cats.
I'm picking up...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, no, I was going to say I was starting
to get a picture for what you were talking
about.
Now that you mention it.
Yes, Cats.
Yes, it is.
Yes, tell us about the movie Cats.
Oh, where to begin?
I saw this movie as joke and then it was the
last movie I saw in theaters for two years.
And that's a fact about me that everybody
should know.
I went as a bit and the joke was on me.
So Cats is-
A bit for no one-
A bit-
By the way.
A bit just so you could say to people-
It's one of those ones that you do for the
invisible audience that you pretend is watching
your life.
Right.
My Truman Show audience.
It doesn't exist.
They're not there.
Nina, let's say that I was somebody who wasn't
familiar with the plot of Cats.
Yeah.
Could you explain it to me?
No, I can't because there is no plot of Cats
based on the musical by Andrew Lloyd Webber.
My nemesis because he wrote it, that's really
the only reason why.
Tom Hooper directed this movie and Tom Hooper
has a history of big-budget, Hollywood musicals
because he also poorly adapted Le Miserable
in, I believe, 2012.
I am not a fan of that adaptation.
I think it's bad.
It's-
It made you feel miserable.
I'm going to move on from that.
So Cats is a very weird musical to adapt into
a movie because it's basically cats introducing
themselves for 90 minutes, and then one of
them gets to die.
That's the end, is that one of them is given
the privilege of the sweet release of death.
And so yeah, you might be thinking, "Why was
that even a musical?"
And it's partly because it was this disjointed,
fun thing that people from out of town could
go see, and the cats would come into the audience,
which sounds very up upsetting to me personally,
but people really liked it because that musical
made so much money, an incomprehensible amount
of money.
So I'm sure that everybody was like, "Cats,
an- It'll be a great success.
We'll get Tom Hooper to do it.
We'll get this all-star cast.
We'll get Taylor Swift to write a new song.
It'll be great."
Spoiler alert.
It was not great.
The movie is a horrifying trip into the uncanny
valley for fans of Polar Express, I guess.
I don't know who this movie is for.
And it is-
There's a part where Rebel Wilson unzips her
own skin.
She unzips her own skin and she eats cockroaches
with human faces on them.
At the end of the movie, Dame Judi Dench looks
directly at the camera and says, "Cats are
not dogs."
That's part of the movie.
I mean, I knew that already.
Yeah.
But it has no context, and you're just like,
"Okay."
I spent a lot of my theatrical experience
of this movie saying the word, "What," really
loudly because there was basically nobody
else in the theater and I didn't care.
It is...
I mean, everybody knows it's a bad movie,
right?
The studio bullied the special effects team
into getting it done faster, so you have weird
stuff.
I saw the cut with Judi Dench's human hand
wearing a wedding ring at the end.
That was...
It's very jarring.
The cats don't have any size consistency.
Sometimes they're the size of a large London
statue, and sometimes they're smaller than
a fork.
I could spend an hour to five days talking
about why Cats is a bad movie.
It's a bad movie, and I still can't understand
how they called Ian McAllen and Judi Dench,
those two in particular, and were...
Because at least Jennifer Hudson got the show
stopper.
She got to sing Memory, which is the song
that everyone knows from Cats, and it's the
only part of the movie that justifies the
existence of the movie even a tiny little
bit because it's a good vocal performance.
But I just can't...
The call to Judi Dench's agent being like,
"We want her to play Old Deuteronomy and look
in the camera and say, 'Cats are not dogs.'"
And somebody was like, "Perfect, great.
And she'll go to cat camp and learn how to
act like a cat," which is a thing that all
the actors had to do.
I mean, I have a guest as to it happened.
I have a guess.
Is it just they told her it would win Oscars
and she did it.
Well, I was going to say it rhymes with dump
truck full of money.
Well, that's the funniest thing is this...
The movie lost hundreds of millions of dollars
when it hit the box office.
Well, sure.
Sure.
I'm sure that Dame Dench made out like a bandit,
but ugh.
I like to imagine that they got these two
critically-lauded octogenarians on the phone
at the same time and said, "Listen, guys,
we are living in an exciting time.
This is the advent of digital fur technology,
and we want to get you guys in on the ground floor."
We want you guys to play cats that don't walk
on all fours, but also do walk on all fours,
but also walk on their hind legs, but also
don't walk on their hind legs.
And...
Right.
Ugh.
The whole thing...
I completely agree.
I saw it not long after it came out, and it
feels very much like falling asleep under
too many blankets.
It feels...
It is a disconcerting-
I felt frightened for a lot of it.
Upsetting experience.
I just felt scared and disturbed, and I don't...
I know it's going to be a big midnight screening
movie eventually one day.
I never want to see this movie ever again.
It hurt me on a personal level just because
it was so unsettling and bad.
It hurt my feelings.
It's so played out to say, "That movie felt
like it was a bad trip," or whatever, but
it really does because none of the rules are
consistent or apply from shot to shot.
And like you said, people, the sizes of everything...
It does feel very much-
And they...
I know, and there is no plot of Cats, but
they try to add a plot while also not trying
to add a plot.
And so it makes the whole movie that much
more confusing and Idris Elba can do magic,
but then that also doesn't matter.
And there are a lot of very good video essays
Out there on YouTube about Cats.
Go find them.
I'm not the expert on this, but it's a terrible,
terrible movie with one of the most stacked
casts in recent memory.
It's...
Yeah.
It's up there.
It's the Movie 43 of this decade.
Speaking of which, while you were talking,
I just pulled that one up because I remember
that when we were initially going to have
this conversation, this is a movie I was going
to bring up.
It's not on our list on looper.com.
Should be.
It probably should be just...
I'll just remind you of some of the people
in Movie 43.
Academy Award winner Emma Stone.
I'm going to stop saying Academy Award winner
because I don't know who else has been awarded.
Please don't.
No, keep it going.
Just guess.
Just say it about everybody.
Academy Award winner Richard Gere.
Academy Award watcher Liev Schreiber.
Easy tiger.
I'll stop doing that because it's a bad joke.
Also-
That's the star of Mixed Nuts you're talking
about.
Dennis Quaid, Greg Kinnear, Seth McFarland.
That's not a big surprise.
Hugh Jackman and Kate Winslet first segment.
I was going to say...
Academy Award winner Kate Winslet.
Yeah.
She's an Oscar winner.
Wolverine.
Yeah.
Hugh Jackman plays a man with an appendage,
a growth if you will, under his chin.
I don't know if we can show the clip right
here.
Let's say this.
Doesn't seem right.
We're either showing the clip or we're showing
a censored version of the clip right now.
So that'll be fun for the editors to figure
out.
Maybe an artistic of it-
Use your imagination audience.
That somebody puts together in Photoshop later.
Movie 43, to the best of my knowledge, it's
basically an anthology comedy movie where
there's just a bunch of different comedy sketches.
Again, "comedy" sketches thrown together starring
huge A-listers.
And then-
Yeah, you're right to use air quotes by the
way because I think the Supreme Court ruled
that legally you cannot call Movie 43 a comedy.
I believe that was a recent decision handed
down by the Court.
I think there was a...
There's some story behind this movie where
people were tricked into being in it.
I don't know.
That's the only explanation that makes any
sense, right?
Yeah.
There's a lot of people who are in this movie
who shouldn't be in a movie like this, but
anyway, I jumped in-
Were tricked into being in it?
Ahead of my turn.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I need to find out.
Tom, in the meantime, while I look this up,
can you tell us about the worst movie starring
a great actor that you'd like to talk about?
Positively, yeah.
So mine is a...
It's a throwback to 1978.
In the months and years following Star Wars'
explosion onto the pop culture scene, there
were so many attempts to cash in on what they
had created, on what George Lucas had created.
But none of them, as far as I could tell,
was as blatant or had as much David Hasselhoff
as a movie called Starcrash, which came out
something like 10 months after Star Wars did.
They started filming not long after the first
Star Wars movie came out.
The director to his dying breath, as far as
I know, just kept saying that, "No, we were
not trying to cash in on Star Wars.
It's just a complete coincidence that the
entire plot feels like you took every plot
piece from Star Wars and stuck it in a Boggle
cube and just shook it until everything fell
into place."
It's terrible.
If you haven't seen it, I mean, by all means,
give it a shot.
It does feel like the fever dream of somebody
that just watched Star Wars for the first
time.
But the best part of it is that you've got
Christopher Plummer.
Christopher Plummer plays the emperor of the
galaxy who shows up to give Shakespearean
gravity to some of the worst monologues-
Oh, man.
In cinematic history.
And he had a great sense of humor about it.
Anytime that he talked about it, he was like,
"They sent me to Rome and that was where...
I would've shot a porn if they sent me to
Rome to do it."
And which is the...
The guy seemed like a real treat.
Oh, yeah.
But it's hard not to imagine that this wasn't
the result of this generation of aging, highly
acclaimed actors who would get together...
Peter O'Toole and Christopher Plummer and
Michael...
And they would all get together and drink
scotch and get punchy.
And at some point, Alec Guinness said, "Look,
I know that everything about this script that
you're getting handed looks like trash, but
this will keep paying your rent for the rest
of your life if you do it.
I just did this thing called Star Wars.
It doesn't make a lick sense, but I will be
okay forever because of it."
"They put me in a bathrobe all day."
Right.
"And they gave me some laser beams to play
with."
"So, please, by all means."
Yeah.
The whole time that he's on-screen, it's astonishingly
clear that they had him for a day and that
they got all of his stuff in one day.
They shot it from two different angles and
then a hologram of his character would show
up and it'd say whatever needed to be said.
But at least he wasn't tricked into it because,
spitballing off the Movie 43 thing, I'm sure
you guys have heard that Bill Murray's explanation
for being in Garfield is it's directed by
somebody whose last name is Coen and he thought
it was a Coen brother.
He thought it was one of the-
He thought it was Joel and or Ethan, and I'm
like, "Buddy, I don't think that's true."
The worst part is that he-
Appeared in the sequel?
Got tricked again for Tale of Two Kitties.
Yeah.
I think by that point, the trick was on everyone
else.
Correct.
But what you were saying, Tom, it reminds
me of Masters of Universe starring Frank Langella
as Skeletor.
Yeah.
But the difference there is he had to sit
through prosthetics and get his face turned
into a skull and deliver these lines.
He's a literal cartoon character.
So, yeah, that's one that should be on our
list too.
And this list that we're talking about is
up on looper.com and it's got a number of
movies here.
I'll just mention a couple.
Leonardo DiCaprio in Critters 3 from 1991.
Clearly, he was a small boy at this point.
Denzel Washington in Heart Condition, costarring
Bob Hoskins as, I think, either...
I think Bob Hoskins is alive and Denzel Washington
is a ghost.
Oh.
Saoirse Ronan in The Host.
Now, you said, Nina, you'd seen The Host a
long time ago.
And I remember very little, which should tell
you a lot, but it's...
I know it's...
It was...
It's based on a book written by Twilight author,
Stephanie Meyer, so I think they thought it
would spawn a very large, similar to Twilight
franchise, which I think...
We're not all still living through Host mania,
so I think it's clear that didn't pan out.
No one here is a Host fan?
I'm team Host.
I'm team Host till I die.
We've got Aloha starring Emma Stone as a character
of Asian descent.
For which she apologized later.
Yeah.
Emma Stone is a white lady and that dovetails
nicely with one of the ones I wanted to add
to the conversation, which was Scarlett Johansson
in Ghost in the Shell, a movie I saw in theaters.
It's real bad.
Real, real bad.
Not a good movie.
We've also got on this list a movie I did
see in theaters, one of the only ones I think
I saw.
Charlize Theron in Aeon Flux back in 2005.
You saw Aeon Flux in theaters?
I saw Aeon Flux in theaters.
Now, the story-
Did you lose a bet?
Here-
Was it a bit?
If it was a bit, I understand.
No.
I love a good bit.
It wasn't a bit.
When I was in high school probably, there
was a thing on television called Liquid Television
on MTV, and it was just weird animated stuff
on late at night for strange people like me
and people who use drugs.
I was not one of them.
Aeon Flux is basically this weird dystopian
sci-fi thing that had spies and espionage
and action and people dying and strange, strange,
strange stuff.
It went from these five-minute shorts to a
half-hour TV show.
It was all weird.
It was cool.
I won't say that it made a whole lot of sense.
The animation style was wild, right?
Very cool stuff.
I mean, again, I was an adolescent and the
way that they are drawing the people in this
show was highly suggestive, so I will fully
admit to that being part of the appeal.
But then I'm in college or just after college,
this big-budget movie of Aeon Flux comes out
and I'm like, "I know this intellectual property.
I will go see this movie.
I remember liking it.
I'll see the movie.
Why not?"
It's one of the only movies I fell asleep
in.
I've...
You rarely fall asleep at the movies.
I fell asleep for probably one-third of this
movie, the middle chunk, and I woke up and
I was like, "I don't know what's going on."
Tom, have you ever fallen asleep during a
movie in theaters?
At the movies.
At the movies?
Yeah.
Almost definitely.
You know what?
The second Alice in Wonderland movie with
Johnny Depp.
Yeah.
I fell asleep during the first act and I woke
up and Wonderland had turned into a scab.
That sounds unsettling.
Yeah.
Unless I never woke up.
There's a chance that I'm still-
You're still in that movie theater.
In the theater.
Still in the movies.
You're going to wake up soon.
Won't you be disappointed.
But that sucks so much more if it's a franchise
that you actually care about and that you
have good memories associated with and then
it's so lame-
I mean, care about might be a stretch.
Enjoyed once, right?
Nevermind.
I enjoyed...
I had fond memories of it and I was keen to
see what they would do with the live-action
version.
Well, and Charlize Theron is a great actress,
so if she's in something-
She's a good actress, yeah.
And this is the movie...
Another great thing here is that this is a
movie that she was horribly injured on and
had to do years of rehab.
Just for this?
Months and years of rehab or something.
Oh, man.
Is that how she lost her arm from Mad Max?
She was almost-
That's how.
It says here in the article, "She was almost
paralyzed during an onset flip going wrong."
I remember that, yeah.
Can you imagine almost paralyzing yourself
for Aeon Flux?
For Aeon Flux.
Those are some of the ones in here.
Another few that I wanted to add to the conversation,
we've got Tom Hanks in The Circle on the list.
Now, Nina, you said you read the book.
I did.
It's not particularly good, and I've heard
that the movie is somehow worse.
It's a clumsy like, "Big tech is bad," story
that's...
That has a...
It has very obvious-
Brought to you by Sony.
Yeah.
It being a movie is pretty disingenuous.
And the Polar Express guy.
Yeah.
And the Tom Hanks villain casting just never
clicked, which I think he later admitted.
I believe that's in the piece on Looper, but
yeah, it just...
The reveals are super telegraphed way too
obviously, and it's just...
The book is not great, and I think...
Yeah.
I mean, I don't see Tom Hanks playing that
character at all.
And so I just feel like-
The guy who played Mr. Rogers-
Right.
Not a convincing-
America's dad, right.
He's not a convincing evil, tech billionaire
who's-
Get Colin Hanks for that, right?
Yeah.
My mom hates that guy.
Really irrationally.
The Casey Affleck of the Hankses.
Yeah.
I like Colin Hanks.
I don't have a problem with him.
My mother wants him to leave the earth.
He was great in The Good Guys a show that
it was canceled too soon.
But on the subject of Tom Hanks, I wrote here
as part of my list, The Terminal, which I
think was...
I want to say...
Was that a Steven Spielberg movie or Ron Howard?
One of those two guys.
It's a big director.
I don't remember which one it is.
Is it also Spielberg after Catch Me If You
Can?
Is that...
He did both?
Oh, he did both.
He might have.
He did both.
That's upsetting.
No kidding.
I don't like that fact.
But so The Terminal, that movie is-
It's a dude stuck in an airport.
Yeah.
Really annoying.
I was really...
I was so mad at that movie I threw a can at
the TV and accidentally turned it off.
And my friend was really into it and was sitting
right in front of the TV, and I turned it
off right before the very end and he was really
pissed off at me.
Nice.
Are you kidding me?
So that's what I want to add.
I would not be upset about that.
I would be thrilled at the fact that I have
a friend-
Who couldn't...
Who has such good aim.
With the uncanny ability to turn off...
Yeah, that's amazing.
I think it was my TV too.
I would just be impressed.
I was ready to do it.
My friend is an-
That's...
And the last one I wanted to add was Jupiter
Ascending, great cast.
Oh, terrific choice.
Channing Tatum.
Mila Kunis.
Sean Bean, Eddie Redmayne.
Academy Award winner Eddie Redmayne.
Eddie Redmayne.
Eddie Redmayne's performance, this is how
he does it.
First, he talks like this.
Mm-hmm..
And then he yells, and that's all he does
back and forth.
Hopefully, the video team will be able to
adjust my volume for that, but he just...
It goes from whispering-
I don't see any reason to.
To yelling back and forth the whole time and
nothing in the movie makes any sense.
It's terrible.
What's that really weird thing that happens?
Does somebody ride a dog through space-
Everything.
Or someone is a dog?
There's something-
Everything's weird.
Channing Tatum is a dog alien.
That's right.
He used to have wings.
I knew there was something about a flying
dog.
See, I was not far off.
Now, he just has-
He still has...
He has hover boots-
That he flies around on.
And when he shoots his gun and I could have
sworn...
And I saw this movie in theaters too.
I could have sworn when he shot his laser
gun, there was the sound of barking underneath
the laser beam zaps.
You might not be wrong.
That's funny.
Yeah.
That movie's really bad.
Not a good movie.
It's a bummer of a movie.
It's not good.
That's funny.
Yeah.
So anyway-
Channing Tatum, he's a really good actor.
I don't know.
I don't have a wrap-up for this.
These movies are bad.
Hey, Nina.
Tom.
Did you ever fall asleep in a theater?
Yes.
And it was what was-
What was yours?
During There Will Be Blood, but I only missed
one subplot.
Oh.
Don't put this on the video.
I was-
No, this is the closer.
I saw a 10:00 PM screening.
It was really late.
Thanks for watching.
Please hit like and subscribe.
We love you.